The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JOHN ESSIGMANN: We're
still on storyboard 7.
We're on panel C.
Panel C is where
I introduced the TCA cycle.
As I mentioned
earlier, respiration
consists of three stages.
The first is the pyruvate
dehydrogenase reaction,
which we just covered, taking
pyruvate to acetyl-CoA.
The second is the TCA cycle,
or tricarboxylic acid cycle
taking that acetyl-CoA
and basically
oxidizing it in
order to generate CO2
but also to produce more
reducing equivalents
in the form of mobile
electron carriers.
And then the third
step of respiration
is taking those
reducing equivalents
to the mitochondrial
inner membrane, where
the molecules containing
those reducing equivalents
are oxidized.
And then, the electrons
from that oxidation reaction
are used to power proton pumps
that ultimately will generate
the proton gradient that can
be used for generation of ATP
or for generation of
movement or for other things.
The tricarboxylic acid
cycle, which is sometimes
called the Krebs
cycle, takes acetyl-CoA
from several different sources.
One of those sources is
glycolysis to pyruvate
and pyruvate to acetyl-CoA,
as we've just seen.
And the second
source of acetyl-CoA
is from fatty acid oxidation.
We'll come to that
pathway somewhat later.
Again, looking at
panel C, the TCA cycle
starts with the reaction
of acetyl coenzyme
A, a 2-carbon compound
with oxaloacetate,
a 4-carbon compound, to form
the 6-carbon product citrate.
Citrate will lose 2
carbons as carbon dioxide,
and in the process, there'll
be a series of oxidation steps
that generate three
NADHes one FADH2,
and one either GTP or
ATP by substrate-level
phosphorylation.
In terms of the banking
system of the cell,
the NADHes that are generated
in the mitochondrion
are exchangeable for
about three ATPs.
FADH2 is exchangeable
for about two ATPs.
So if you look up
the total number
of nucleotide triphosphate,
or NTP, equivalents
that can be produced
in the TCA cycle,
you'll get about 12 ATPs
for each 2-carbon unit
of acetyl-CoA that's oxidized.
As a detailed point,
I want to mention
that the two carbons
that entered the TCA
cycle as acetyl-CoA are
not exactly the same two
carbons that come out
as CO2 in that cycle.
The carbon dioxides from
the input acetyl-CoA
will emerge in later
turns of the TCA cycle.
Now we're going to look
at panel D. In panel D,
we start looking at the
details of the TCA cycle.
JoAnne explained why
nature uses thioesters.
The sulfur allows
enolization stabilization
of a carbanion at carbon
2, the carbon that's
distal to the coenzyme
A functionality.
The carbanion is then able
to attack the number 2
carbon, carbonyl,
of oxaloacetate
in the reaction catalyzed
by citrate synthase.
An intermediate is formed,
citroyl coenzyme A,
which loses its coenzyme
A moiety by hydrolysis
in a very thermodynamically
irreversible step,
resulting in the
product citrate.
This step is at the
top of the pathway,
and as is usually the case,
this highly exothermic step
makes the pathway,
overall, irreversible.
Chemically, citrate
synthase does
a mixed aldol-Claisen
ester condensation.
The product of the citrate
synthase reaction, citrate,
is a tertiary alcohol,
and tertiary alcohols
are relatively
difficult to oxidize.
The next enzyme in the
pathway, aconitase,
which is shown in
storyboard 8, panel A,
removes a water molecule and
then adds a different water
molecule back to rearrange
the hydroxyl group,
making a secondary
alcohol, which
is much easier to oxidize.
Looking again at panel A,
the hydroxyl group of high
isocitrate is
oxidized to a ketone,
with the transfer of hydride
to NAD+ to make NADH.
This reaction is catalyzed
by the enzyme isocitrate
dehydrogenase, ICDH.
The intermediate
in this reaction
is oxalosuccinate, which
is a beta-keto acid.
As we know from what
JoAnne taught us,
beta-keto acids are prone to
spontaneous decarboxylation.
So the second half of the
isocitrate dehydrogenase
reaction involves the
loss of carbon dioxide
in what's usually considered
to be an irreversible step.
I do want to point
out, however, that
under certain circumstances,
you can re-add the carbon
dioxide in order to
make the reaction go
in the other direction.
After the ICDH reactions, which
generated NADH and resulted
in loss of CO2, the product
is alpha-ketoglutarate,
a 5-carbon keto acid.
Take a look at the structure
of alpha-ketoglutarate
in the upper right-hand
portion of storyboard 8,
panel A. If you hold your
finger over the top 2
carbons of
alpha-ketoglutarate, you'll
notice that the
residue is pyruvate.
So pyruvate plus an
acetyl functionality
equals, effectively,
alpha-ketoglutarate.
Now take a look back
at the mechanism
by which pyruvate is oxidized
by pyruvate dehydrogenase.
It's going to be a very similar
mechanism for the oxidation
of alpha-ketoglutarate.
The product of the
alpha-ketoglutarate
dehydrogenase reaction
is succinyl-CoA.
Again, if you look at the
structure of this molecule,
succinyl-CoA, it's actually an
acetyl-CoA with an acetyl group
put onto one end.
Now let's go back and look
at the alpha-ketoglutarate
from a different perspective.
I want to make a point here
in that alpha-ketoglutarate
is an alpha-keto
acid, and if we were
to replace its keto group
with an amino group,
you'd convert this
keto acid into
the amino acid glutamic acid.
As with most enzymatic reactions
involving such nitrogen
functionalities, a pyridoxal
pyridoxamine phosphate cofactor
will be needed to interconvert
the alpha-ketoglutarate and
glutamic acid.
So glutamic acid can serve as
a source of alpha-ketoglutarate
if the cell is starved for
TCA cycle intermediates.
Alternatively,
alpha-ketoglutarate
can be a source
for glutamic acid
when a cell may need amino
acids for protein biosynthesis.
Now, let's turn
to panel B, where
we'll start with succinyl
coenzyme A. Looking
at the molecule of
succinyl-CoA, note
that I've labeled each of
the atoms with a symbol.
The triangle and
square were from
the original acetyl-CoA
molecule that came
in at the top of the pathway.
The enzyme that processes
succinyl-CoA is succinyl
coenzyme A synthetase.
As JoAnne taught us,
synthetases are enzymes that
typically need a nucleotide.
In this case, the
nucleotide involved
is GDP in mammalian systems
or ADP in bacterial systems.
In the traditional clockwise
direction of the TCA cycle,
they are phosphorylated to
form GTP or ATP, respectively.
The molecule that you get after
the phosphorylation reaction
in the hydrolysis
of the coenzyme A
is succinate, a
4-carbon compound, which
is also a dicarboxylic acid.
This molecule is
perfectly symmetrical
and can tumble in
three-dimensional space.
The next enzyme in the pathway,
succinate dehydrogenase,
cannot distinguish one arm
of its substrate, succinate,
from the other.
So if there were a radio
label in the acetyl-CoA
at the beginning of the
pathway, that radio label
would become scrambled
at this point,
uniformly distributed among the
two carbons of the two arms.
From this point onward
in the TCA cycle,
you will note that the label
denoted as the triangle
and box is scrambled, as
indicated by triangle divided
by 2 or box divided by 2.
The next enzyme in the pathway
is succinate dehydrogenase.
This is the only membrane-bound
enzyme in the TCA cycle.
It is a dehydrogenase,
and it uses flavin
as a cofactor to
help remove electrons
from the succinate substrate.
Flavin picks up
electrons from succinate,
converting FAD to FADH2 in
the mitochondrial membrane.
The product of the reaction
is the alkene fumarate.
The enzyme fumarase adds water
to fumarate to form the alcohol
product malate.
The hydroxyl group
of the alcohol malate
is primed for oxidation by the
next enzyme in the pathway,
malate dehydrogenase, or MDH.
MDH oxidizes malate, which
is an alcohol, to a ketone.
The ketone product
is oxaloacetate.
The hydride removed from malate
is transferred to NAD+ to form
NADH.
As I mentioned, the product
of the overall reaction
is oxaloacetate, and
its ketone functionality
is now primed for attack by
the next molecule of acetyl-CoA
entering the TCA cycle.
As a final point, I've
mentioned several times
that oxaloacetate is present at
a very low concentration, only
in the micromolar range,
inside the mitochondrion
of a mammalian cell.
So it's always at rather
limiting concentration.
The cell has to work very
hard to preserve enough
of the oxaloacetate to enable
the next cycle of the TCA
cycle, that is the acquisition
of the next acetyl coenzyme
A group.
One of the ways that the cell
can generate oxaloacetate
is by deamination, or
transamination of aspartic acid
to the keto acid oxaloacetate.
We typically have
plenty of aspartic acid
and this PLP-mediated
reaction helps
to maintain a critical
level of oxaloacetate.
I want to return to storyboard
7 to make some comments
about the importance
of prochirality
in some enzymatic reactions.
This short interlude
will help explain
how to track a radio
label in a TCA cycle
intermediate as that
intermediate progresses
through the TCA cycle.
As you will note,
at first glance,
the label does some
unexpected things.
But at the end of
the day, the fact
that the label does
surprising things
helped early biochemists
figure out mechanistically how
several enzymes work in
concert during the linear steps
of a pathway.
We're going to look at
storyboards 7, 8, and 9,
starting with the
chemical reaction
at the bottom right
of storyboard 7,
panel D. This is the
chemical reaction that's
catalyzed by citrate synthase.
You'll notice that
I've highlighted
the two carbons with
either a triangle or a box.
As we have seen, the
nucleophile on acetyl-CoA
attacks the
electropositive carbon
of the carbonyl functionality
of oxaloacetate.
The carbonyl functionality is
a flat sp2 hybridized center.
So if this were a typical
organic chemical reaction,
the electrophile could
come in from either the top
or the bottom, and you'd get
two different stereochemistries
in the product.
That is the citrate
at the very bottom
would have equally labeled
acetyl arms at the top
and bottom of the
molecule as I've drawn it.
You would have a delta divided
by 2 for the blue methylene
group, and a box
or square divided
by 2 for the red
carboxylate group in each
of the two acetyl arms.
Again, these arms are at the
bottom and top of the molecule
as drawn in the
lower right of panel
D. You'll note, however, that
only the top acetyl group
of citrate has the labels.
Initially, the observation that
only the top arm acquired label
was a puzzle to
early biochemists.
One way to think about the
citrate synthase reaction
is to think about the
oxaloacetate laying
on the surface of the
citrate synthase enzyme.
Now imagine that the enzyme
precludes, or blocks, access
to the carbonyl from the
bottom and allows access only
to the top, giving
rise to only one
stereochemical outcome, the one
that I've shown in the citrate
to the right.
Now move ahead to
the storyboard number
9, panel B. This panel
shows a more cartoon-like
representation of the
molecule of citrate.
You can see the acetyl arm
on the top, the pro-S arm,
as having the labels.
And the pro-R arm, the one
that came from oxaloacetate,
at the bottom, is label free.
So while the pro-R and pro-S
arms are chemically identical,
they're going to be
handled by the next enzyme
in the series, aconitase,
as being chemically
different from one another.
All biochemistry is
going to be occurring
on the pro-R arm,
that is the arm that
came in from oxaloacetate
and not the arm that
came in for acid 2
with acetyl coenzyme A.
In the bottom right
of panel B, I've
sketched out an imaginary active
site for the aconitase enzyme.
I show a base
picking up a proton
from the pro-R arm of
the citrate molecule.
And you can see the elimination
of the water molecule
from the 3 carbon.
So despite the fact that the
citrate molecule is chemically
symmetrical, aconitase, the next
enzyme in the reaction series,
is able to distinguish between
the pro-R and the pro-S arms.
At this point, I want you to
look back at storyboard 8,
panel A. Look once again
at the citrate that
is at the upper left-hand
corner of storyboard number 8,
and let's imagine that
the aconitase chemistry
has happened on the pro-S arm,
that is the one in the box.
Keep in mind that these
experiments have shown
that this does not happen.
This is just a
hypothetical scenario.
In this hypothetical
case, the hydroxyl group
would end up on the
number 2 carbon,
the one with the blue triangle.
You have to draw
it out, but if you
traced this molecule, in
which the chemistry happened
on the pro-S arm, all the way
around to alpha-ketoglutarate,
you would find out that
the alpha-ketoglutarate
dehydrogenase would liberate
CO2 from the carboxylate that
has the red box on it.
This is in contrast to the
molecule succinate that appears
on storyboard 8, panel
B. Succinate is another
symmetrical molecule,
but for some reason,
succinate dehydrogenase cannot
distinguish between the two
acetyl arms.
Because the enzyme is unable
to distinguish the two arms,
in this case, unlike
that of aconitase,
the radio label would
become scrambled.
The reason that I'm
belaboring this point
is because one of the ways
that biochemists work out
the chemical reactions involved
in a biochemical pathway
is by putting in some
kind of labeled molecule.
It could be a radio
label or a heavy isotope.
And then they trace the position
of the label in the molecule
as you move from molecule to
molecule along the pathway.
So label tracer studies are
ones that are absolutely
central to all of biochemistry.
And as I mentioned
earlier, you'll
get lots of experience
in the problem sets
in using labels to work out
the details of a pathway.
Before leaving the
TCA cycle, there
are a couple of big picture
points that I want to make.
You put in two
carbons as acetyl-CoA,
deposit them into
oxaloacetate to form citrate,
a 6-carbon compound,
and then in the cycle,
you lose 2 carbons
as carbon dioxide.
That means that
there's no loss or gain
of carbon in this cycle.
If you had just one
molecule of oxaloacetate,
you'd be able to
complete the TCA cycle.
What happens,
however, when the cell
is in an, let's say, "energy
needed" situation, where
it needs to buff
up this cycle, that
is increase the number
of molecules cycling
to be able to accommodate the
processing of more and more
molecules of acetyl-CoA?
Those molecules of
acetyl-CoA might flood in
from carbohydrate metabolism
or, as we'll see later,
from catabolism of lipids.
Let's look at panel
A of storyboard 11.
As shown in this figure,
one way to accomplish
increasing the carbon
content of the TCA cycle
is to take an amino
acid, such as glutamate,
and remove its amino group
to form alpha-ketoglutarate.
Note that if you increase
the concentration of any one
molecule in the TCA cycle, for
example, alpha-ketoglutarate,
you're effectively
increasing the concentrations
of all molecules in the cycle.
Because it's a cycle,
many of the molecules
are in equilibrium
with one another.
Going clockwise around the TCA
cycle from alpha-ketoglutarate,
we come to succinyl-CoA.
Succinyl-CoA is an entry
point into the TCA cycle
from odd-chain fatty acids
in certain amino acids,
such as methionine.
So these molecules can
give rise to succinyl-CoA
that itself will then
increase the concentration
of all molecules
in the TCA cycle.
Our third primary input
point is at oxaloacetate.
It involves aspartic acid being
deaminated into oxaloacetate.
This is a very common
way to increase
the amount of oxaloacetate
available for the TCA cycle.
This reaction can dramatically
increase the rate of processing
of molecules by the TCA cycle.
Finally, there's an
enzyme we'll look at later
called pyruvate
carboxylase, or PC,
which can take pyruvate in the
mitochondrion, add CO2 to it,
and form oxaloacetate.
We're going to
come to this enzyme
later when we talk about
carboxylase enzymes as a class.
This is an important enzyme in
the pathway of gluconeogenesis.
So overall, I think you can
see that there are several ways
that a cell can increase
the overall concentration
of the intermediates
of the TCA cycle.
Increasing any one intermediate
increases all of them.
And that will increase
the rate by which
acetyl-CoA molecules can
be processed ultimately
to generate energy.
The general word describing
this buffing up of the TCA cycle
is anapleurosis, which comes
from the Greek word "filling
up."